>> Tucker: THERE'S A LOT WE
DON'T KNOW, BUT WILL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW THE STORY AS IT DEVELOPS.
THANK YOU.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS REFUSING
TO FUND ALL WALL.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED HE
PLANTS US ON THE MILITARY TO
GUARD THE BORDER WITH MEXICO.
THERE'S A CARAVAN THAT'S MAKING
ITS WAY THROUGH MEXICO TOWARDS
OUR COUNTRY.
THE CONVOY WAS BROKEN UP ON
MONDAY AND DEPORTED 400 PEOPLE
IN IT.
THE PEOPLE RUNNING THE CONVOY
SAY OTHERWISE.
DON'T BE FOOLED, THE GOVERNMENT
ISN'T DISBANDING IT, IT'S
CONCEDING THE RIGHT TO APPLY FOR
ASYLUM WHILE TRAVELING IN THE
SHALLOWS.
IN 2017, THE MEXICAN FOREIGN
MINISTRY PRODUCED A VIDEO
ENCOURAGING MEXICAN CITIZENS TO
BREAK IMMIGRATION LAW.
HE TOLD HIM TO HIDE THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE THERE ILLEGALLY AND
IT WAS NOT THE FIRST ON THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
THAT.
IN 2004, THE GOVERNMENT PRINTED
AND DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN
1 MILLION AND A HALF PAMPHLETS
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANS
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANH
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANW
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANT
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANO
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANE
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANT
TELLING AMERICA         MEXICANR
AND NOT BE DETAINED.
RECENTLY MEXICO FILED A BRIEF
PROTESTING THE CENTURY CITY
BILL.
THE MEXICAN FOREIGN MINISTER HAS
CALLED FOR THEM TO RECEIVE LEGAL
STATUS AND ANNOUNCED THE BORDER
WALL IS A HOSTILE ACT.
HOSTILE?
MEXICO IS A HOSTILE POWER HERE.
JUST TODAY, FORMER MEXICAN POWER
TWEETED THAT TRUMP IS THE NUMBER
ONE ENEMY OF MEXICO.
HE THEN RETORTED SOMEONE ELSE
WHO SUGGESTED THAT IF A DISPUTE